douglas i haven't seen you this animated
before
and we've spoken to you several times
are you concerned that
things are getting worse sure i'm deeply
concerned
i think we're standing on a genuine
precipice
and it's getting worse all the time
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry from
our brand new studio in the heart of
london
i'm francis foster i'm constantly
kissing and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
and a fascinating first guest of the new
season we have for you he's an author
journalist most importantly he's here
for the fourth time
ms murray welcome back to trigonometry
it's very good to be here i can't
believe four times
four times and um helping to break in
your new set
you are indeed it is an absolute honor
to have you back you've just written
an afterword uh for the madness of
crowds the book that is now
a bestseller pretty much overnight uh
it's been
a tremendous pleasure to read it to talk
with you about it in the past
but i want to go back to the last
conversation we had via zoom
not quite as good as this when we were
talking
probably i would think it would have
been april perhaps early may
very beginning of lockdown yes and we
were talking about
is china going to need to pay for some
of what's happened
you know all and i remember you sort of
dismissively going if only we could stop
talking about this woke [ __ ]
i think those are your exact words
believe it or not
um it was a sort of like minor thing in
the background that if only we could
just ignore these silly people
on university campuses who are going off
the deep end
and get on with the adult business of
discussing the things that adults should
discuss
the world would be a much better place
well i put it to you
douglas that in the months that have
passed between then and now
we have seen that this worksheet is
actually existentially threatening to
everything that we hold dear isn't it
yeah absolutely i mean i
uh i think i've always spoke in the
spirit of optimism
more than anything else i i i mean
everything we know about
kovid has changed in the months since we
last spoke um
and i think when we were speaking then
we were at the very heart of the feeling
that actually we were undergoing a
generational pandemic that was going to
see each of us lose a swathe of our
friends and family
and at that point it did seem like
a lot of the crap receded for a time you
know there are examples i give in
in the updated version of the massive
crowds you know
the obvious one is sam smith sitting in
his mansion crying and posting that on
social media so that people feel sorry
for him
they them and uh
of course various people said well at
least they have themselves for company
but but uh sam smith
um sanders didn't get much sympathy
because
everybody was in the [ __ ] you know um
we were all even if even if the
mortality figures weren't it weren't
going to be as high as
it first predicted you know massive
numbers of people were out of work
isolating their houses not able to see
their loved ones not able to go to
funerals or weddings and
so everyone had a lot of reasons to
complain
and it was my assumption that in a time
when we all
had lots of reasons to complain we
wouldn't have much time for
people with fake complaints you know at
a time when
at the very least significant
unemployment starts
to rocket you know somebody says you've
misgendered them or used the wrong
pronouns
desire to say f off finally finally
kicks in
and that was my feeling at the beginning
it was real complaints
that we all now had we didn't have much
time for people with imaginary
complaints
and i thought that was going to hold and
it did hold right
up until events in minnesota
and i think the historians will say that
all of this was a sort of perfect storm
you you know you have a lockdown where
the first time in modern history
everybody is told to stay in their
houses a tory government tells everybody
in britain to stay at home and
we do there's an interesting corner we
might not have predicted it
and uh what's moratory government says
that everyone who is young and not in a
committed relationship
must be forced into celibacy for months
that again
i'd be surprised if any of us had
expected that
but then when the killing of george
floyd happens it was almost almost like
a
combination of things happened the first
was
clearly people were fed up of lockdown
and to a great extent and obviously
there were sincere protesters but there
are also people who are just delighted
to have a
reason to get out of the house and start
mingling again
and then there was this particular sort
of concatenation that it was
an anti-racist cause that was
able to explode and come out at that
point
and i think yes that in the period since
all of the things that we had hoped
might go away
have just burst out and
i think we've said before that that as
andrew sullivan said a little while ago
we all live on campus now but
this is now all of us living on a
violent campus it's like everyone's
living on evergreen
in 2017. um
and this is the moment where all of the
theories
and the intellectual thinking about
stuff
starts to be it starts to become clear
what we were worrying about
you know that it's not it's not just
play acting
and by the way i do think that
is to that extent what we were engaged
in right up until recent months
you could even see it with some of the
tests as important they were
they were playing at being like you know
they had these weird black block things
they'd advance behind umbrellas
like a sort of post-apocalyptic roman
legion
and these sort of desiccated
pseudo-warriors we're confusing real
life and
computer games and and much more
they call it larping exactly larping
it's a very useful term and and then
we see that thing where the game
stops and people start firing guns
people actually start to get their heads
and skulls smashed in
and then everything changes this isn't
laughing anymore this isn't
this isn't computer game stuff this is
the real world
and i think we all but america in
particular is standing
on a precipice do you think douglas
a lot of people have said this that
kobud actually acted as a catalyst
for all of these particular issues that
this was inevitable
this path that we were going to tread
but with everybody locked down with
everybody being exposed to social media
24 7
it's just sped the whole process up it
is interesting that
you we've all had first time in our
lives
an inability to be able to judge what
our fellow human beings friends family
are
thinking and doing as you know this
better than anyone as comedians you
you know you you develop extra sensory
perceptions in your fingertips you can
you can judge
whether something's going to land right
if you have people in front of you
you what is it when people talk about
public mood but
a sense because you and some people
really have it and some people think
they have it
um a sense of what the public are
actually thinking or feeling
that's because we interact and we meet
people and we sense what happens i'm
standing beside somebody in a shop or
speaking to a friend or hearing from an
audience
strip all of that away isolate people
in their homes for many people in a very
solitary situation
and we all lose that and so online
becomes the only way we can imbibe ideas
and that's why
it's so complex with blm because for a
chunk of people
they actually think that this
is what it says it is i mean as you know
you you
took some heat for this but you said
early on this is itself a validly
marxist organization
well lots of people just didn't believe
that because they only had
the screen and by the way this has been
happening in american cities where i
i've had this experience i'm sure you
have where
some american friends say my
neighborhood's just been burnt down or
all the shops in my neighborhood just
got looted and then other people say oh
no it's just peaceful protests and then
you notice that the people who say it's
peaceful protests haven't moved back to
their own neighborhoods
things like that it's an evolving story
you mentioned the the peaceful protests
and again
last time when we had you on the show we
sort of
moaned a little bit didn't we about how
of the media were asking boris johnson
stupid questions about
the covert response and i feel like in
the last three months i mean
what has been happening in the united
states particularly but also with the
bbc here
uh reporting on riots and calling them
largely peaceful
cnn reporters repeatedly standing in
front of burning cities
yeah and saying that the idea that the
violence is happening
is a myth that's the enemy they're
standing in front of a burning city
he was particularly good wasn't he
comical ally or frank drebin in
police forces nothing to see here when
the firework factory is going off behind
me
i love it please move on there is
nothing to see here
and as much as we can laugh about it and
laugh we should of course we should
the the derailment of the media the
derailing of the media from
reporters of information with a slant
perhaps as well
until a year ago to now just full-blown
unabashed propaganda did you didn't you
think one of the most extraordinary
things everyone's forgotten about it now
the attack on cnn headquarters in
atlanta
so the crowd gathers very early in blm
start smashing through the glass front
of the cnn headquarters
these are not trumpies you know these
are not
like maga hat wearers this is the blm
protesters they start smashing in
that one of the reporters is reporting
from the lobby of his own workplace
and his the people he's broadcasting to
upstairs are telling him to get away for
his own
safety and nobody
cnn says don't do this
get away they report it as if it's a
sort of normal thing
to have an invasion of a network
by hooligans and they don't they're not
even on their own
side these je these so-called
journalists
nobody called it out none of the other
networks seemed to be bothered
nobody seemed to mind nobody said this
was an attack on the free press
but why have we got to that's put to
this point where you can't criticize
them
and if you do criticize them like i
found out it doesn't end well
you have to find a new studio yeah and a
new home
here's the best steel man
explanation they think that there
it's a disagreement about the proximity
of fascism
if you believe that the fascists are
about to take over or have taken over
almost anything goes okay
everyone's been taught this all their
lives
what we're living in is a problem of
people who think the proximity of
fascism to their front door
is wildly close and they have completely
misinterpreted their universe
because by any fair estimation
there is no support
for fascists in a country like britain
one man some anti-covert protest the
other day appeared to have like waved
the the the strike sort of
symbol that was mostly i british union
of fascist sort of symbol
and never said oh my god the fascists
are only openly protesting again in
london
as far as i can see from that that's one
guy some old lunatic
who may well be a fascist himself he has
no support
he has no support now unfortunately
there are a lot of people who think for
instance and have got away with thinking
that fascism is right in front of them
and around them
all the time they think that donald
trump is a fascist
god knows none of us have a paucity of
complaints to make about donald trump
a fascist i don't think so
i don't think so not by any definition
fascism i know
uh the tory government
no not by any reasonable estimation
i think it's absurd that we're even
talking i know but
we have to accept that there are people
who have been taught and
told and whipped perhaps some honest
people into the
belief or imagination
that is the situation and that they
live in a state which is going to be
fascist any moment by the way
that is not a totally new thing
this has gone on for two generations at
least
um in 1968 in the student protests
uh this was a common theme as well in
america
and britain and other western countries
the idea was
that the the state was essentially
proto-fascist
that the police were the the most
visible
wing of that and that if you
pushed the police sufficiently they
would reveal the true fascist
nature of the state uh my late friend
five james and i often talked about this
uh he was in cambridge in 68 when
the garden hotel in cambridge was
famously the crowd as i started to smash
the hotel and i remember clive described
how
he and others said whatever you think of
this the moment you throw the first
brick
everything changes but these students at
that point
who were prosecuted that's what they
thought
they thought that you could reveal that
the state was truly fascist and of
course
one of the things that the 68 is
then learned even the most vociferous
ones people like danny cohen mended from
germany and so on
what they started to learn was that of
course they ended up as
the establishment you know they ended up
all the blairites were also
you know people within that sort of
radical left former radical leftist
milia
who made a fundamental misunderstanding
about the state not all of them but some
of them
and then they were the state clearly the
state wasn't fascists
and people just pretended that they
hadn't had their embarrassing youth or
what you know whatever they could do to
sort of gloss it over but we never
really confronted that
that those fundamental lies and in
recent years they've clearly grown and
grown
and yes you i mean you know the
james lindsey and helen pluck rose in
their excellent new book uh
talk about this the way in which these
theories on campus
about the nature of the state the nature
of society and if you're
told by everybody in authority that you
live in an oppressive patriarchal
quasi-fascistic state
you're going to have a misunderstanding
about the nature of the society you're
in
and if on top of it you haven't traveled
very far you don't know any
damn history or anything else
the i'm giving you my most generous
interpretation of what i think is going
on
because that is a problem isn't it that
we throw these labels about we say that
boris johnson is a fascist but the
reality is
these people don't know the meanings of
the terms that they're using
look at the one look at one of the even
worse ones the way the left
the the labour party members and labour
party mps
have thrown around the accusation ian
duncan smith killed hundreds of
thousands of people in the early part of
this decade during the coalition
government
that's a completely normal claim made on
the left
it's outrageous it's defamatory i don't
say that because i'm a member of the
conservative party because i'm not
i don't say it because i agree with
everything it's outrageous
as a claim and yet it's made all over
the place
all the major left-wing you know
corbynist the journalists all made it
for years
they went around telling people ian
duncan smith murdered
thousands of people in britain
and that wasn't a problem and i think
the point you're really making that
douglas is that
this debasement of language over time
where people who have nothing to do with
fascism
are being labeled in this way and
ordinary people some of them are being
convinced that this actually is
true well if i put myself in that
position
and the third reich is rising again
i suppose would be the fourth rank now
if the fourth reich is upon us
well why wouldn't you be on the street
with exactly batons
and in fact it's one of the few things
society that we all agreed on
you know it's one of the few things we
all agreed on we're not doing that again
and the conversation jordan peterson and
i had a couple of years ago
you know we agreed basically you know we
i think we came to the formulation in
the end that we
all almost learned one of the two
lessons of the 20th century
but they almost learned the lesson on
fascism was was pretty near
but certainly we have a this is why an
almost
total societal revulsion
of fascism and i'd add something more on
that
we have an almost total societal
revulsion
of racism and so again
if you think we live in a racist society
and you've had pumped around for years
the allegation that we have a racist
prime minister
running a racist tory party and
you know they all found these little
nasty lies didn't they that you know
the extraordinarily ethnically diverse
british cabinet that we have
was only a cover or their only uncle
tom's all these nasty little tricks
the left and the far left played all
these years
this is the fruit of their labor you can
see the beautiful fruit of their labour
in the mobs that ran rampant in this
country for a short period
and that are running far more rampant in
america to this day
and douglas what's happened to common
sense
because you've got terrible ideas and
you get you know you get fed terrible
ideas
but surely you have your common sense
where you analyze the idea you go well
this is palpable nonsense
or you do the reading or you analyze it
well it all makes you worry doesn't it
about the fundamental
the most disconcerting idea for anyone
who cares about ideas
is that reason isn't enough
you know um
miguel du una muno the uh uh
spanish philosopher pre-revolutionary
spanish philosopher
described being in a meeting once in
spain where the um
the the crowd stands chanting what was
it
my spanish in the viva la
what is this necrophilic chant
i mean it is how could anyone
and that's what always worries people to
think
what if everything we put all of our
attention into isn't enough it's a
terrifying thought
and time and again i remember when the
um
when the rwandan genocide um occurred
there was one news report of
a man being murdered by the rival tribe
masking everyone and uh
and some he was a doctor shot in the
head and the man who shoots him says
he's a doctor what good are these brains
this is this is the you know what
happened a couple nights ago in america
a man is is shot
and immediately you have a crowd on the
streets
with a woman shouting through a
megaphone
i do not care that a fascist was killed
tonight
of course because you've you've labeled
the victim of the murder you
incited a fascist and everyone's been
taught not to mind if fascists are dead
you've just moved the goalposts to make
fascists
majorities of populations that's why
we're in this mess
and then you don't mind about the
killing and then you're back into viva
la muerte
uh territory again and this is
this is why you know i've i can never
understand
why the blame never gets to the right
doors on this
it never gets to the right doors you
know
the people who make false allegations
about the nature of the state
frivolously erroneous accusations
against individual citizens or
politicians
that they never have to pay a price for
that
douglas i haven't seen you this animated
before and we've spoken to you several
times are you concerned that
things are getting worse trying deeply
concerned
i think we're standing on a genuine
precipice
and it's getting worse all the time
because of this misunderstanding
misinterpretation of our societies
and what i mind is that this is the best
chance we have you know
there isn't another option we don't have
for instance if we're going to go back
to this
line of racial segregation this time
enforced by so-called anti-racists
we go back to hell absolute hell
and you can feel it daily what's eroding
is the settlement that we had
on that you know sam harris and i have
said before you know
we had hoped to arrive at a stage where
skin color was as
unimportant as hair color
and now these people come along it's
like having a ginger separatist movement
you know i i mean to decide we should
only speak about hair color for the rest
of our lives
then creates countervailing forces and
much more but it's like the settlements
that we were hoping to head towards
are being pulled apart by people who
seem gleeful at
pulling away the threads of our society
they seem positively gleeful about it
and that goes back to your point about
reason
that's because there is an instinct that
drives
people to you destroy
it's it's there throughout human nature
the instinct to destroy is very strong
the
high octane of enjoyment of destruction
isn't it also because it's easy douglas
it's far easier to destroy than it is to
create
that's right that's one of the central
burkina insights
um yes you you can pull
pull a thing down in a second and it
takes a long time to build it up
you can destroy a building or a statue
in no time at all
it might take somebody an entire
lifetime to create it
and so we find ourselves in a very
sub-optimal condition because
the desire to pull down is clearly rife
but
maybe this is an evidence that people
have to endlessly relearn
the same lessons you know there's a line
in elliot and murder in the cathedral he
says
men do not men do not learn very much
except that from generation to
generation the same things happen
again and again men learn little from
others experience
you're sounding very apocalyptic douglas
and i don't blame you because i don't
disagree with you and the question that
francis and i
really both wanted to ask is do you
think
we are past the point of no return now
no i don't i'll tell you why
these are the circumstances outside
but the circumstances outside are always
bad
they're always bad now there's
particular peaks to the mania
i've been reading quite a lot about
revolutions recently for
obvious reasons um
and it's just so striking the extent to
which this is
it's just what happened in 1789 it's
just what happened in 1917
i was reading the other day an account
of in the days after the revolution in
1917 vincent petersburg
when you know law and order of course is
all fallen apart
but people are sort of starting to
police themselves and sort of quasi
no one quite knows because of course the
revolution was meant to bring peace but
no one actually focused on any of the
details just like in 1789
so nobody knows what to do when things
go wrong like crime and there's a
description
an incredibly haunting description i
read of on a tram in saint petersburg in
1917
a rather well-dressed woman and there's
a rather well-dressed man
near standing near her and he um she
starts screaming
she thinks he's stolen her purse and
everyone gets interested
and they start finding out what's
happening the man insists he hasn't
stolen her purse
and uh a couple of men who were sort of
self-appointed police at this point
decided he
must have done clearly and they take him
off the town and shoot him in the head
and they get back on the tram and the
woman finds that the purse has fallen
down the lining of her coat
and then they have a problem of course
so they'd take her off the tram and
shoot her in the head as well
it's a russian way mate what can i say
that's how effective
you know and that's what happens
in revolutions that's what happens when
everything starts to break down
that's what's happened in kenosha
briefly
that's what happens when you know one
person thinks he's going to go and
protect a shop
and then gets appears one particular
case that i'm thinking about obviously
appears to have been
separated from other people and then the
people who are the protesters and
recognize who he is
and then before you know it he ends up
shooting three people dead
you know that's what happens what's
happening in portland people being
dragged out of their cars and smashed in
the head or
shot that's what happens when everything
else breaks down but
so we might be in one of these periods
and it might get a lot worse yet
or it could get better but the reason
for optimism on it
is that this is what history is always
like and we've had a very blessed
time in our lives so far and
i don't need to tell you to all of us
here know something a lot of people
outside this room don't
which is we're the luckiest damn people
in history
and luckier than any of our forebears
and luckier than we have any right to
expect
but it was always like this in history
and the thing that's most important the
thing in a way i
think is most important for us all to be
thinking about and the people watching
particularly young people watching to be
thinking about
is this it's always
like this to some extent and don't
wait for more optimal conditions before
you do what you're meant to be doing in
your life
because the optimal conditions will not
be arriving
and it's a great point you make and do
you think part of the reason we've come
to this point is because of cowardice
and i use that word in its truest sense
of a lot of the mainstream media in
particular the left
the center left who seem unwilling to
stand up
and say to these people you may be on
your on our side you may be on
our side politically but what you are
doing is fundamentally wrong and
destructive
yes and they or they want power more
than they want
truth but sorry to interrupt douglas i
mean i don't think
you can lay the blame for that only with
the left i mean look at boris johnson
on on blm he he did very little said
almost nothing
yeah to to to to his to tackle
there were two excuses for that which i
don't like
at all one is that he was still ill yeah
possibly but in that case somebody else
from the government had to make a stand
the second is that some people say this
is a typical boris johnson tactic that
his desire
tends to be to wait till there's massive
overreach by his opponents and then
say something if he's not overreached
when the cenotaph is being attacked i
don't know what is
you know or when the winston churchill
statue is being attacked
but your point still stands which is
cowardice is that how it is
cowardice a desire for quiet life um
but as i say also prioritizing the
search for power over truth
you know the new york times which is
just a lost publication now clearly
um you know has has deliberately
inverted the nature of these riots
as pro-trump supporters become more
violent
protesters have to work out how they
should react was one of the
headlines something like that one of the
headlines they did the other day as if
the sort of black block protesters just
sitting around a rather a contemplative
body these are these uh protesters
uh so yes those people
want to be in power more than they seek
truth
which is a calculation that will come
back and bite them at some point
and hope it bites them fast but probably
not
um but to come back to this point
it's it's really crucial i think we
start to bear this in mind we've spoken
before about the over
emphasis of politics in all of our lives
the way in which it's become
almost a full-time occupation for too
many people
you know um and
i mean i think that when politics is
gets as bad as particularly america now
is
people start to wonder what they can do
and other than voting there's not very
much that most people can do
other than influencing the people around
them what i'm worried about is this
endless opportunity cost
you know park rose and lindsey say in
their book at one point
what would have happened if the
academics doing all this complete
wank about you know intersectionalism
and you know
comparative feminist theory and the
intersections with disability and fat
studies what if they'd have done
something meaningful with their time
what if they'd studied something that
was of importance
what if all of that brain power and it
must by now be a considerable amount of
brain power
had been expended on a worthwhile
problem well maybe we'd be a bit further
forward
what of those people brought us i
thought nothing
but now it turns out it's worse than
nothing it's an
actually malevolent malignant thing that
they have been injecting into the
thought of our society
so again just to come back to this point
what do we do as individuals about this
we all have a limited amount we can do
in our personal lives in terms
of trying to correct untruths correct
false narratives
but other than that i think it's a very
important message we remember you
you shouldn't put off what it is you
should be doing with your life
nevertheless i was i was reading the
other day it was an extraordinary sermon
by
um given by c.s lewis in 1939 when the
war has started it's a very
very brilliant piece of prose and lewis
says there
he says you know these are southern
paraphernalia
you know these are these are sub-optimal
conditions
[Music]
and he says he says but but anyone who
puts
off what they're meant to do to wait
for the optimal crisis you'll realize
that they will never come
and there is something highly unusual
about our species
that we're not like other species you
know the
the ants found their own accommodation
and look after their
you know physical well-being and the
well-being of the colony but human
beings are different
and i think what's it lewis says he says
you know we are
we are beings who he says discuss
mathematical theorems in beleaguered
cities
we we make jokes on scaffolds
we talk about poetry when advancing at
the walls of quebec
comar hare at the gates of thermopylae
says this is not panache it's our nature
it's our nature as human beings we do
extraordinary things in the face of
terrible beleagueredness
and confoundedness and confusion
but it was always like that it's not an
excuse
and do you think part of the problem is
as well especially in america more than
it is here in that
people are disenfranchised by the
democratic system like you look at the
democrats
with biden in charge you look at
republicans with trump
and you know whatever happens if you're
amongst the very poor whoever you vote
for
nothing's really going to change well it
could do
and it can do i mean by the way actually
i'm not a supporter of trump but
the job figures until the carpet crisis
suggested there was something he could
do
and if you're a poor working class
person in a relatively poor state in
america
having a job or not having a job is
important
much more important than all of the
abstract things that we could talk about
you know i mean obama for instance you
know who had many virtues but i mean
there was an awful lot of just lovely
rhetoric
and um you know for most people it's
very basic things that
more like to change their life having an
income being able to provide for their
family
that's the most important things and so
there are things that can be done
and you can always moan about your
present political class
again i mean everyone all my life
has moaned about our political class
that's part of the joy of being in a
free society they're never good enough
i mean even as a famous example everyone
gives it
churchill in retrospect is universally
or
was to everyone decided that he was the
worst racist and a totally unforgivable
figure
used to agree that he was a good friend
but you know everybody's public famously
rejected him election in 45
we always moan about our political class
do you think that's it you said
something that douglas about
not knowing how good you have it which
is really what you're saying
do you think we have had minor
aberrations aside
since 1945 this tremendous period of
perpetual growth yeah endless stability
every generation that came after was
wealthier
it was freer was safer lived longer
wherever you look any metric you measure
by we have just had this extraordinary
life
in the west did we forget
the other side of the coin did we forget
that the moon can be light and dark that
life is pain as well as pleasure did we
forget that
that's the philosophy cited early
spanish philosopher um
famous book uh the third is the tragic
sense of life
um something i suggested in my last book
but one stranger of europe was that
western europeans and americans had
forgotten the tragic sense of life
i mean to a great extent we suffer from
a lack of willingness to face up to the
most basic facts
you know i mean i've always been
interested in the way in which the
spillage
of christianity and post-christianity
means that you have certain things still
in your society which are not willing to
confront so for instance
it's a bit of a bleak one but when
people die there's still a tendency to
sort of they're
with the angels now and you get
i mean i know metaphysical systems in
which you can believe that but
what's yours that allows you to believe
that or say that
you know um rest in peace those sorts of
things like
yes there are systems of belief where
you can say that but
if you don't believe in any of that it's
like
well yeah i mean there's no other option
and
we have lived for a while in a weird
metaphysical system where we have a bit
of the hangover
of that belief but it means that we're
totally unwilling to confront that
so we're willing we're unwilling to
confront the reality of death
famously in a society like us have been
for a long time many people have pointed
this out
death is something that occurs elsewhere
in
retirement homes and in hospitals
you know graveyards are way out of the
center of town
you know everything everything we can do
to keep the realities of life away from
us we do and there are
answers that are non-religious to that
but we don't bother with them either
i mean in my view we could do for
instance with a dose of stoicism
that would be much much more useful than
for instance
the medicalization of everyone in
society to to help avoiding
truths we don't want to face up to much
better that everyone got a dose of
marcus aurelius or somebody who says
these are
the facts of life that are unalterable
and this is how we can cope with that
terrible knowledge this is one means of
training ourselves to do so that would
be quite a useful thing
to teach in schools for instance
but we haven't done any of that we've
run off this sort of
diluted content-free post-christianity
we've run off as jonathan height and
others have pointed out
the the the fumes that we've
got that are positive from
our success in 1945
and they've been running lower and lower
and lower
and and at the same time people have
been told life will
give you the following things and of
course you'll get that and you deserve
this you deserve
that and and what if that's not the case
what i mean i would have thought in an
era we're going into the living
standards that are going to decline for
all of us
i can't see how they can't and people
said that after
the 08 financial crisis which we still
haven't got over
um so i would have thought if that's the
case we should prepare ourselves for
that and that
that's not a totally hopeless exercise
you know things have gone down
before it's just i'm sure like me you
have that feeling that
if the party's over for a time at least
people ought to be prepared for what
that feels like rather than standing
over demanding that the party continues
to be
laid on for their personal enjoyment but
isn't also part of the problem that you
know
for these people who've come and
graduated university after 08
the party's over sure and in a way we've
discussed this before how can you expect
them to believe in capitalism when
capitalism is doing very little or
nothing for them no i agree i think
there are big questions that shouldn't
remain unanswered or so little answered
this long
i think that wanting to get onto the
housing ladder
feeling like you never can these are
very
that problem's about to be solved
douglas
[Laughter]
yeah yeah could be um
but it's very demoralizing for people
that sort of thing and i i noticed that
you know
people who are sort of big defenders of
the status quo have not
have not been doing a great job in
shoring it up
i don't think by the way capitalism per
se is responsible for that i mean
there's a
longer debate but i think it's there's a
form of capitalism which can go wrong
which everybody knows about and
there's a sort of corrupt crony
capitalism yeah but i don't even i don't
even think we particularly live in an
area of
crony capitalism we certainly don't in
the uk
um so what is it then how has capitalism
become distorted
well for instance for instance zero
interest rates i mean this is an obvious
one for this long because
you do that in order to help get
yourself out of the last financial
crisis
but it means that nobody's rewarded for
saving yeah
and in fact the inflation ends up
meaning that
what you're saving is worth less and
less or
you know i mean the response to the to
the 2008
essentially we had a medical problem we
emptied the medicine cupboard
without dealing with the problem and
it's just waiting to come back
but the empty the cupboard is empty
that's what's
that's what's coming yeah and i mean
there are people who who say i mean i'm
not an economist i just
there are people who say to me you are
economists that you don't need to worry
that the
the perpetual growth keeps going anyway
or that
um i was having this argument with
somebody the other day or that the debt
can continue to be accumulated
yeah mmt the idea that you can print and
borrow money
and i just you know that worries me
because i don't i don't see that i think
they're an obvious consequence
all the time yeah it's weird like you
can just spend money
endlessly in the house but but but
historically what always happens
by the way i actually i have a great
friend who's an economist born in india
who will deepak lal who some time ago
described to me going to university
somewhere in america i think it was
asking to see their um library they
showed the library said where's the um
economics section they said oh it's all
online said but what are all the books
about economics he said
they're all morrigan i mean because
we've learned now what
and he said he realized this was
increasingly a study
that believed it had no history you know
and
that's why the history of economy is so
interesting is because people
some people in it think it's like
medicine there's
a book on economics in the 19th century
has no more to teach you than the book
of medicine from the 19th century
because we know more
and the problem with economics is
actually there's lots of stuff you do
know
but there's also history recycling
itself in certain
ways and in the case of economics the
kind we're going through at the moment
the that's one of the reasons why
everyone feels very very worried about
the moment we're in is because
ordinarily
just financially take away these other
bad signs
what normally happens at this point is
it all gets corrected by a war
yes absolutely and this has been
something that i've
i've been thinking about this whole time
which is
obviously our reading of history is
perverted by that
dogma that it's written by the winners
and so
and such a weird claim that isn't it
because it's not true at all i mean lots
of time the losers write the history
sure what what i mean more accurately i
think is that
our reading of history is based on
things that happened as opposed to
things that were avoided
do you see what i'm saying let me
elaborate so for example if a plane
crashes
that's a huge event if a mechanic
tightens a ball
that prevents a plane from crashing that
never gets covered in any way
uh nasa talib writes about this in the
blacks one so
the question that has been borrowing
away into my head this whole
three months or four months is has there
ever been a time in history
where we have been on the trajectory on
which we are now
so far down that trajectory and there is
no question that the trajectory leads to
what you've just said which is war
and we decided you know what let's
step back from the precipice let's stop
this madness of crowds let's
remember that as individuals we have the
capacity to think
and reason well i mean you you can
hope that that can happen because i go
back the experience of the individual
because there is something very
instinctive in us when we know
we get suddenly a glimpse of what it is
that's about to happen
i was reading a lot of tolstoy and
lockdown and uh when he's so depressed
you russian writer um
but there there's a that's that
magnificent description in war and peace
of the two sides of the army coming
together you know they have the gap
between them and they know as they're
facing each other but just a
centimeter forward and you are into this
other terrain
and the other terrain is where
everything happens every limbs hacked
everyone
but as long as you're standing there and
you haven't taken that
small step into that terrain
that small step is everything
and all of us sense
that the people engaging in violence in
america in particular the protesters in
the uk you could see it
they were testing whether to dare to
take that step
into that terrain and actually in this
country partly because eventually the
policing
became okay you realize that you can't
step there always all changes in america
it seems that some people have started
to step into that
terrain now some of them might
immediately see
that it ends up with people being shot
through the skull
and they might see an exit wound of a
bullet for the first time in their life
in a human being and think you know what
maybe we get back to the formation we
were in before maybe that was more fun
and there will be others who will enjoy
being in that train but i
i have some confidence that once people
see
what they're about to step into they
will step back
so i hope um
and is that how crowds work though
douglas well
the other option of course is you do get
in again i go back to
these events in kenosha the other day
you get
that and then you never know where you
are
because suddenly the melee i mean you
know
i wrote some years ago book about the
events of bloody sunday in northern
ireland
and i i have a particular interest in
this thing of what happens when the
first shot fires
because when the first shot fires the
perception of everybody outside is well
then you knew that for instance that
person fired from there and that person
fighting
you don't have a damn clue what's
happening once it kicks off
once violence kicks off you don't know
you don't know where the sound is the
recall the bullet you don't know where
it is
the rebound of a bullet you don't know
who shot where it's a free-fall the
whole thing
so yes that's the other option and
this is why it seems to me
that the aim of the era is not to join
the crowd
you must have seen as i did those that
amazing footage
of the restaurants in washington dc of
these
totally reprehensible spoiled
mainly white as far as i could see
college-age
kids going around and demanding that
restaurant goers
put their fists in the air there's a
black power salute some people say the
salutes for something
related as ever they you know pretend
the whole thing is
is a mystery even whilst they're
enforcing it on the population
but like taking the knee is it's all
this sort of
modern crass i iconic they just want to
force it doesn't matter in a way just so
long as you demoralize people enough
that they do the thing you tell them to
do
take the knee raise your fist jump
and they go around all these restaurants
and do this you can see that the
clientele some of them uh they
they go downstairs in the restaurant and
you know you see these like they're just
like you know some of them just start
doing it anyway
and then it's like you know and then
they also say [ __ ] the police and then
you can see one of the guys like oh i'm
not sure about it
um but in that situation there were some
people there's one woman
in one of those videos who doesn't do it
and the whole damn mob is around her
screaming to her to do it
and she won't be that woman
be that person do not join the crowd
do not do what the mob demands be that
woman
doesn't matter what the mob demands it
matters less what the mob demands and
that you do not do what the mob
says so there are people
and that examples like that throw up
these people
that woman may not have known that she
was that sort of person
she may not have known that she had the
heroic quality needed and it is heroic
to say no i will not join the madness of
the crowd
i will remain a human being with my own
sense of dignity and my own sense of
self-worth
and you will not demoralize me because i
know that if i do this you will demand
that i do something
next and it seems that
these crowds have a narrative they
adhere to a particular narrative
whatever it may be maybe the black lives
matter narrative of you know racism is
everywhere we live in a racist structure
of oppression all the rest of it
why has it come to this point now where
if you don't adhere to this narrative
if you don't go along with it it can't
just be that we're two people
who have a difference politically why
has it got to this point
that you must be cancelled destroyed
defenestrated and
ultimately ruined because the crowds are
good
they're really good they really know
what they're doing
i mean i'm in this position where i can
say whatever the hell i want
why because i don't owe anything to
anyone really
i mean my editors papers i write for
could
be persuaded not to publish me i suppose
my publishers could be persuaded not to
publish me but
i other than that i don't have anyone i
sort of
need to have on side maybe i shouldn't
have given that list of people
i come to think about it uh no i mean
but most people aren't in that situation
most people are beholden to someone
yep they have an employer they teach
somewhere and there is a boss or there's
a board their company and so on
and those people are in a very
vulnerable position and they
are um being well
picked off by the current mob
and the mob is not just physical it's
obviously online
and they come for people and they make
them essentially unemployable and that's
the aim
so as i've probably said to you before
those of us who aren't in that
vulnerable position i think have a
disproportionate duty to say the truth
as we see it even if we're wrong
and i have no doubt like everyone i can
be wrong
um but the thing that alarms me is
that things we could all say until
yesterday have become impossible to say
you know i have this
example i give in the manners of crowds
about relations between the sexes and
in the chapter on women we all know in
our society the the
the motif of the predatory male
we all know that one almost all
news about relations between sexes is
about the dreaded
alpha male and the predatory alpha male
uh
well the left-wing community yeah yeah i
i was wondering why it was
like a female i was just getting ready
to make the same point i've made on
every live stream for last two months
just enjoying the fact that
you know all these wonderful people who
are very
kind and compassionate turns out right
well
the first thing is of course of course
as we've discussed before there within
that is the people who are actually
predatory males who pretend to be little
yes little uh harmless little men who
say oh i'm a feminist
and i'm from black lives matter and i do
all these things and then turn out to be
rapists and rapacious perverts of every
kind but
that's not the point the point is that
we knew that
and we've always known that and there's
also always been another thing in
history
which is the rapacious predatory female
totally familiar type literature is
filled with it shakespeare revels in it
chaucer revels in it every single
civilization and country has a version
of this literature and we pretend now
that there's no such thing
as only the predator i mean samson and
delilah samson and delilah
every single tradition has predatory
females
but our age has decided since yesterday
there is only the predatory mail
so most people pointing this out get
into a whole world of trouble say to
most bosses in an office
is there such a thing as a woman who'll
do a certain amount of stuff just to get
somewhere
let's see whether he wants to have that
car you know you were right you know the
first time we interviewed doug
uh francis lichty and went you know what
douglas he's a bit of a troublemaker
possibly but not you know
mischievous i think sometimes but the
point is is that
there's a lot of stuff we all knew till
yesterday on this yes
yes and i'm and i think we should all be
worried that this stuff which is true is
not able to be
acknowledged and that's the case
now overwhelmingly it's becoming clear
that that is the
in the racial thing this is becoming a
particular issue because what we what
we've done is among other things
subvert a whole load of discussion and
and as i say my own hope in all of that
has always been that well my own belief
in it is
you you you have only two ways to go on
the race one
you either you either do what people
like me had put
our store in which is you say it will
it should we should seek to get to a
society where
it's as unimportant as hair color and i
grew up in
london in which that was to my mind and
some people say well you would say that
because you're white wouldn't you
but to my mind into my mind my
contemporaries and my friends
i thought that had basically happened or
was in the process of happening
that's one option we are united by
certain civil and other
you know you you unifying factors
and race is an unimportant element of
that now in the name of anti-racism a
group of
people have come along who said no no no
no race is the only thing that matters
and if you say that it doesn't matter
you're racist and if you said it does
matter you're racist
and everywhere you go you're you're
racist and
then you get people into the great
double blind moves that everyone's been
been getting caught in by total crocs
and fraudsters like robin d'angelo
money-making
monsters who goes around american
college campuses
and and affirms and charges and tens of
thousands of dollars
to tell them that if they say they're
racist they're racist and if they say
they're not racist they're racist
and the only best correct answer is to
always say you're a racist
we should have got into that right she
was gone at the ground
floor mate you're definitely racist
though what can i say
and and these people have come
therefore with the only other option to
the one
i could put my store in which is okay
it's about race well here's a warning on
that one even if you don't want to go
down all of the other warnings you can
do on it
even if you were of the group pushing
that
step back because it's not going to work
what is the black population in america
13 13 you think that
that a population that is still a
majority is going to forever
suck up the claim that they're evil
no but this is where the war part comes
in right
and it's the same in this country to a
lesser extent you think that most of
white people are still a majority in
this country i hate talking about that i
hate the idea that we have to talk about
white
people and black people but fine if they
force us to do that
let's just do the maths on that white
people remain the majority in this
country
you think they are going to be happy to
be told your past was disgusting and
reprehensible
and not just ordinarily reprehensible
but uniquely reprehensible
none of your forebears are of any worth
your society didn't get anything that
was good other than by
stealing it what you have now you do not
deserve
you should give it to other people you
should give it to other people who look
like people to whom things were done in
history because you look like people who
did some of the things that were done
we will ignore anything bad done by any
other group of people other than you
you've got to do this for all the rest
of time are you happy with that
you think you're going to win you think
that the british public's going to deal
to suck that up forever you think that
they're going to be willing to sit there
and take it as they're told
that our forebears all had the best
imaginable time
you think that's going to work oh it
might work this year
it's not going to work for very much
longer and i can see
exactly what the play is that comes back
which is that's a shame we have put an
awful lot of faith in this pluralistic
multicultural ideal turns out it wasn't
wanted
how do you unknit that without going to
hell
these people are playing with the most
dangerous
elements of our society and they're
like they are it's like seeing
a child
playing with a nuclear device
and we've got to stop her but don't you
think the problem is
so for instance in venezuela in 99 when
chavez came to power
he had a lot of the same ideas a lot the
same rhetoric that black lives matter
espoused i saw what happened
in venezuela a lot of people don't
understand what it is to live in a
communist society
they don't know what it means you know i
i have people coming up to me and going
you know cuba's not all bad
it's always meant to be the school good
weather
good weather nice cigars as well yeah um
it's always meant for the schooling
system isn't it the health
yes yeah there's always some crock there
always was doing cold war as well yeah
there was obviously always a certain
type of fool
who could tell you how great something
was
um
maybe one of the most important tasks of
our time is for everybody
of your age younger
older to tell more about this
i am going back to that thing i said
about almost learning one of the two
lessons of the 20th century
why don't we work harder at teaching
telling people explaining whatever voice
we have however we do it
what that second lesson ought to have
been
you know and again the formula that
jordan and i came
to some time ago was how about trying to
work out where the left
goes too far right we all know where the
right goes too far the right goes too
far and gets into the worst possible
territory
when it starts playing games of racial
separation or racial superiority
not that the left can't do racial
superiority claims but it's more
historically it's more being a factor on
the right yeah the far right
um and could be again on the far left
where does the left go to the far left
nobody seems to care nobody seems to
know
um the obvious place is to put it at
equity the search to make everybody
equal by the way
i think my gut i think it's a disgusting
idea i don't want everyone to be equal
you know i don't like
equality in sports i don't like it
in any other realm of life you know
i i i like human difference i i don't
want everything to be this flat
monochrome monotone boring society
but some people do seek at least a
greater degree
or put a greater emphasis on equality
than for instance than i do and then to
equity
well that would be where the left goes
wrong has always gone wrong
why don't we start to name names put
blame
why do we start to to
put the blame at the doors of the people
who make this happen again and again
and make sure we learn nothing from
others experience in venezuela
in russia in cuba everywhere else
why don't why don't we start to trace
this you know because we still
all of us could must be able to agree
that
the amazing thing that the left got away
with in the 20th century was that it got
away basically scot-free
and the right didn't and for good reason
and the left somehow did
was because we needed the left to defeat
the right that's why
yeah and that made sense at times you
know i mean i have a great degree of
sympathy for people who actually did
think that communism was the only way to
to cancel out fascism at a certain point
yeah until sergeant wrote the kind of
well one soldier
after hungary after czechoslovakia after
solzhenitsyn how the hell do you still
think that well
also after 1945 in general you know i
mean
but but i have some sympathy for people
do i have sympathy for people who
became fascists because they thought it
was the only way to
deal with communists no
that's an example of the inequity of the
calculation i'm just describing for some
reason i mean i have that too
why because we we focus more on are more
maybe it's also because in western
europe the communist threat didn't come
as
completely close as the fascist threat
did there's something in that simple
geographical issue
but why why is it that we are still in
this situation in 2020 where they fly
the marxist
banners they fly the soviet flag they'll
play a soviet anthem they'll
put their they'll play games they'll
wear t-shirts of che guevara
and they'll admire venezuela and they'll
they'll they have this horrible roster
of
first and second class sadists
and they still think that they can make
it work and why aren't they more shamed
about it all
after this amount of time it's not like
it's a damn secret anymore
well it's been great opening the fresh
season of trigonometry with an uplifting
episode
yeah there was a massive amount of time
for gags i know yeah yeah
but douglas i do think it's important
that we talk about this
in this way too because i think people
need to understand
that the time for half measures and for
wishing it all
would just go away and we can stop
talking about
the worksheet that time's over now sure
that time is over sure this is the time
for the opposite of the cowardice of
francis talk about yes
this is the time for people who can
we're privileged you're privileged in
that position to have that freedom
but it's also now time for other people
to
to in their small ways not to raise the
fist not to
bow to the mob not to join the mob and i
think the message that
you have carried and your book presents
to people is exactly that
it's an important message right now
and you talk about it and afterwards
that you wrote to the
to the madness of crown just now every
time you publish a book now
you expect that it will be the last book
you publish
it's true it's true but but this is why
it's so important
that you do and it's why it's important
that we have these conversations and
it's important that
other people who can do the same
and i hope that watching this listening
to this gives them some measure of
inspiration to do that because
in my opinion that is the only way we
get out of this
i completely agree so with that in mind
we've got one final question for you as
always which is what's the one thing
that we're not talking about
that we really should be i think we just
talked
about it actually i think it's that
thing
i think it's finding and agreeing on the
place where the left goes wrong
and i think it is people
it should be incumbent on people to know
their own ignorance
on this if somebody said to you
what's auschwitz
that person is
ignorant wickedly ignorant
they should not say that nobody should
say that
if somebody said to you who is polpot
that person is also ignorant in an evil
way
if they don't know by now
they should know and we should make sure
they know
thank you for coming back it's been a
pleasure
thank you so much for watching guys uh
if you want to follow us
please do and also remember that we go
out our episodes
are wednesday and sunday 7 p.m we also
have live streams don't we concentrate
every other day except monday so we will
see you at 7 p.m i love the way we ended
on a very dark note
and now now we're just brazenly plugging
ourselves
uh for the capitalist returns that we
deserve yeah we'll see you very soon
uh with another brilliant episode take
care
and thank you and see you soon
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word